and have been watering wine I did not
demand a trial by combat to at least try
to avoided that sentence a trial by
combat is a method to settle accusations
in which two parties in dispute fight in
single combat the victorious party is
held to have had his or her case judged
fairly by the gods and has proven their
innocence in the eyes of the gods long
story short if the accused parties
victorious they are cleared of all
charges but if the accused or their
champion is defeated however then they
are considered guilty and condemned to
death in the words of Tyrion Lannister a
trial by combat decides a man's guilt or
innocence in the eyes of the Gods by
having two other men hack each other to
pieces the first rule of a trial by
combat is that only high burn noblemen
have the right to requested in the other
words small folk do not possess this
right as we all know Eddard Stark was
the head of House Stark the Lord of
Winterfell Lord paramount and warden of
the north in other words give us a
highborn nobleman with the right to
request this kind of trial let me also
say that if a highborn witch net
certainly was is accused of a crime at
any point during the trial held by the
local Lord he can demand his right to a
trial by combat this right is held to be
so inviolable that even a lord or the
royal family that is fully convinced
that the accused should die would be
hesitant to simply denies such a request
if made in public so Wynette did not
demand the same let's first look flew
the fact of not being really injured
since the accused may ask for a champion
to represent them just like Tyrion the
advice the main reason why Ned did not
but also could not demand the trial by
combat is because unlike Tyrion Ned had
already confessed his guilt in front of
everyone as well remember nettles
promised that if he would plead guilty
the Lannisters would keep his daughter
sensor safe and he on the other hand
would because Isle to the Nights Watch
to live the rest of his life on the wall
there never was a trial since Saturday's
the safest daughter and therefore a
trial by combat could never happen once
then confessed his guilt was established
and he could no longer demand the trial
this kind nor off any other kind but
then there's another question that
brings us at the very beginning way
before Ned had confessed why didn't I
just accept the deal in which he was a
traitor instead of demanding a trial by
combat
true he accepted it for the sake of his
daughter and family but what life could
then did for that matter since I have in
the cirrie ruled over by the Lannisters
living with Joffrey and Cersei as a
daughter of a traitor regardless of net
being alive and well on the wall as
planned
or executed instead
of the great Sept of Baelor point being
why not take a chance and try to prove
your innocence in a trial by combat that
would give him and his daughter a chance
to avoid any punishment this is why many
fans are wondering if Ned made a good
decision by blindly accepting versus
promise
there's however another fact that seems
to be an answer to this question trial
by combat is the fate of the seven
tradition valid on the other hand
worship the old gods of the forest in
conclusion even if Ned did not confess
he still most probably would not demand
the trial by combat